الدكتور هيثم محمد ابراهيم وزير الصحه
الاتحادي المكلف دكتور هيثم مرحبا بك معنا
على شاشه العربيه عشرون يوما منذ بدا هذا
الصراع وهذه الازمه في السودان الى اين
وصل معها الوضع الانساني والصحي حسب
تقييمكم
شكرا جزيلا
طلال الفتره بتاعت الجمله الاخيره
والتقارير الينا من كليه الولايات السودان
معظم الولايات التي كان لها سباق سابق
وبلغت 12 لكن حاليا عندنا
غايه الخرطوم وبعض النزاعات في ولايه
غريبه
حركه الامداد وبعض المستشفيات العامله
بصوره كوميديه حسب تقاريرا مركزيه حتى
الان عدد الوفيات الوارد الى المستشفيات
او عبر المختلفه
حوالي 551
قديم في هذه الدول وصلت هذه المستشفيات
وهذه المشاريع وقرابه الخمسه الف حاله
اصابه تم التعاون العام في الولايات
السوداء طيب
المستشفيات ايضا ما هي الاوضاع فيما يخص
العاصمه
الخرطوم خرطوم بحري ام درمان هذه المناطق
التي يدور الاشتباك دكتور
بالنسبه للمستشفيات ولايه الخرطوم فيها
حوالي 130 مستشفى زينب مستشفى خاص
المستشفيات المركزيه في مواقع الاشتباك
ومعظم المواقع في بحريمان توقفت عن الخدمه
تشكل تقريبا حواليكم 30 مستشفى اي تقريبا
قابله للخدمه بعض المستشفيات المركزيه
للاسف بها قوات الامام السريعه ارتكاز
مستشفى
الزرقاء المركزيه مستشفى النساء والتوليد
في ام درمان
هذه المستشفيات حاليا خدمه لهذا السبب لكن
بقيه المستشفيات
حوالي كمثمانين مستشفى في اطراف ولاده
طرطوم وكذلك الولايات القريبه كيولات
الجزيره ولايه في تحويل بعض الحالات
للمعامله في هذه الولايات
هل هذه المستشفيات لديها القدره الطبيه
والكوادر ايضا الكافيه
يعني سد حاجه المناطق المحيطه به حول
التعامل مع الحالات التي تصلها دكتور
بالنسبه للكوادر هو العدد بتاع القواعد
الصالحيه او الطبيه في السودان كبير
الولايات تم حوالي الخرطوم مستقره ولايه
الجزيره وولايه نهر النيل حتى تم تحريك
بعض الطبيه من الولاده الخرطومات القريبه
من ولاد الجزيره قريبه من الكرتون
بالتنسيق مع عدد من الجمعيات الطبيه
والمتطوعين في ولايه الخرطوم الاشكاليه هي
امكانيه وصول الكوادر لهذه المستشفيات
خاصه بيحتاج احيانا يعضروا بعض المناطق
اللي بيكون فيها نزاع مسلح لكن
الكوادر تشتغل هذا القرمله يعني الكوادر
الساكنه في درمان مثلا يتم استغفاره للعمل
بين الشاحنين مثلا في بحريه يتم استفاضه
لذلك
بمبادرات مع عدد من الجهات تم تشغيل
المراكز الصحيه حتى تتمكن من
الصيام ببعض القنوات الاساسيه دكتور
اليونيسف قبل قليل ذكرت بان هناك نهب
لاكثر من مليون لقاح للشراء للاطفال في
السودان اولا اتحدث عن دقه هذه المعلومات
وعن حاجه الاطفال اليوم في السودان
لهذه اللقاحات مثل هذه الظروف
بالتاكيد اللقاحات للاطفال دمتم الخمسه
المهمه في مكافحه الامراض الطفوله
برنامج التفصيل في السودان في ال 18 ولايه
تاثر بصوره اساسيه في ولايه
جنوب دارفور
سلسله التدريب
بقيه الولايات
المركزيه في الخرطوم السودان ما اصاب شيء
واجهات اشكاليه بتاعه الكهرباء والوقود
وتمت معالجتها في الايام الماضيه بقيه
الولايات ما فيها اشكاليه في تسيير
الخدمات الروتينيه للتطعيم سواء كان شبه
الاطفال او غيره بالتاكيد في تعاون وسند
كبير جدا للمنظمه الصحه العالميه ومنظمه
الانشاء في هذا الباب وهم معانا في
المركبيه والعواصف دائم في سد الفيديو
حاليا طيب هل هل وصلت الى السودان اي
مساعدات من هذه سواء من الصحه العالميه
ومنظمات الاغاثه الدوليه ايضا وغيرها
اتحدث عن المساعدات
الدوائيه التي وصلت الى السودان او الى
ايضا حتى العاصمه الخرطوم تحديدا
وصلت بالتنسيق مع عدد من المنظمات الدوليه
وبرضو الاصدقاء
ومن الدول العربيه الشقيقه
تم تحديد اولا الاحتياجات الاساسيه في
قواعد محدده من الغرفه الامداد المركزيه
الصحه الاتحاديه
متضمنه الحوجه في جانب
المستهلكات الجراحيه الادويه الاساسيه
لامراض المزمنه
الامراض الكلى وبعض المدخلات للصحه العامه
وصحه البيئه تمت استجابه واسعه جدا الكثير
من الشركاء بعض المنظمات لديها امداد
موجود داخل في السودان تم تحريكه كمنظمه
الصحه العالميه ومنظمه اليونيسيف وتمت
الاستفاده منه في بعض المستشفيات كذلك بعض
المنظمات الاخرى اطب
مختلفه
ومشاركات وتشغيل بالاضافه لذلك تم تحريك
الامداد داخل السودان بين الولايات
المختلفه للعلم
المركزيه انها 18 سنه في ولاده السوداني
بهذه الفروع يوجد بعض المخزون الدوائر تم
تحريكه بين الولايات المختلفه
برضو مع تم الاقامه وزراء الصحه العرب في
اجتماع منظمات الجامعه العربيه
دول العربيه حتى حاليا
ونشهد بدايه وصول حزب من الامدادات الطبيه
وفق الحوجه من عدد من الدول العربيه على
الاشتقاء من الكويت من قطر من سلطنه عمان
بدانا نستلم بعض المعينات الاساسيه عبر
منفذ البحر الاحمر
بورتسودان تحديدا الدكتور يعني انت ذكرت
قبل قليل ان هناك اصحاب امراض مزمنه وربما
ايضا حتى من تطول مده بقائهم في
المستشفيات من المصابين بالسرطان او
بامراض الكلى وغيرها هذه المستشفيات التي
كانوا يعني مقيمين فيها كيف تاثرت بانقطاع
التيار الكهربائي المستمر في العاصمه
الخرطوم
كونا اللي جاي من كل التخصصات لجنه خاصه
بامراض الكلى على سبيل المثال لجنه خاصه
بامراض السرطان وتم تحميل
للعلاج في مستشفيات اخرى بالتاكيد هو
مستشفى واحد لكل الاورام ولا مستشفى واحد
على سبيل المثال مراكز السودانيه واربع
مركز
اكثر من 80 مركز حاليا شغاله في اداره
بتبدا المشقه على المرضى هي تحريكم من
مراكز لاخره بعيده من المناطق احيانا
النكته الثانيه بالنسبه
للادويه خاصه لامراض الكلى وامراض السرطان
اصلا سياسه السودان قبل هذه الحرب هذه
الكامله من المواطنين تتلقى هذه العلاجات
مجانا من برنامج يسمى بالعلاج المجاني
المخزون الموجود في هذه الامراض في مكان
حوالي
55% قبل الحرب في بعض الاصناف كانت مطلوبه
مثلا على سبيل المثال الغسل
غسيل كلا لمده ثلاثه اشهر القادمه سيتم
توزيعه المختلفه
كانت اشكاليه لانه كان الموجود بسيط لا
يفيد
التعاون والتنسيق مع بعض الجهات شركه
الحكمه الاردنيه تبرعت بمجموعه من العاديه
دكتور دكتور اخيرا
دكتور اخيرا كيف
تستطيعون او من يؤمن ايضا حتى حمايه هذه
المستشفيات من ان لا تتحول الى تكنات
عسكريه كما تحولت بعض المستشفيات
دي واحده من اصعب الملفات حديثا معقده جدا
نحن في الصحه وعبر اللجان العليا لتنسيق
عمل الخدمات الطبيه والانسانيه عملنا
مناشده ومناداه بعدم اتخاذ المستشفيات
الصحيه سكنات عسكريه ووجهنا رساله واضحه
وعدم اتخاذ هذه المستشفيات كمقارها
والسكنات وكذلك رساله
البريد هذه المقارنه تكون مواقع
للاشتغال نامل الاستجابه من
الدعم التاريخي في الابتعاد عن المستشفيات
الصحيه خاصه بعض المستشفيات في مستشفى
الجره و بعض المعمل القومي
قد يكون كل شيء من الخطوات اشكرك جزيل
الشكر الدكتور هيثم محمد ابراهيم وزير
الصحه الاتحادي المكلف شكرا جزيلا لك
القصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات